Now, the first 1 is actually quite trivial; so first of all, vertex cover is a minimization problem,
so we're looking for a vertex cover that is as small as possible.
Now, if the algorithm already finds one with 100 vertices,
then that means, in an optimum solution, there cannot be more than 100 vertices.
Because we already know that there's a vertex cover of that size,
the optimum solution might be smaller, but it will certainly not be bigger.
Now here comes the interesting part. So we just said vertex cover
is a minimization problem, which means if you have a factor-2 approximation algorithm,
then the solution that we found, and we found a solution with 100 vertices,
is ≤ 2 x the size of an optimum solution.
Which means if you solve this equation, that the optimum
is at least as big as 100/2, or 50.
So the minimum number of vertices in an optimum solution is 50.